there are games that we keep going back
to whether that's because of a car
mechanic a feeling it evokes or an
update which makes the game feel new
again one of those games for me
[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I've teamed up with those legends at
Phoenix labs once again to bring you ten
reasons to jump back into free-to-play
behemoths dauntless nope no pun intended
now it's left early access and is a
fully released title so let's do this
[Music]
I'm going to start with the greatest
thing dauntless could ever have added a
new weapon type but not just any weapon
ether strikers we now have the ability
to punch a hulking great behemoth in the
face it feels good I can't put into
words how satisfying it is these
gauntlets are available in every
variation you can imagine every behemoth
we face to this point has a variation of
this new weapon so go punch things the
ether strikers themselves stand out from
the other six weapons as they use
mantras here let's quickly break them
down there are three key combos to learn
three square inputs gives you fast quick
hits that don't consume stamina then
there's three triangle inputs which give
you a truly heavy barrage and then there
is square triangle triangle for a
mixture of both quick and heavy attacks
but here's the cool thing if we complete
one of these combos we unlock a mantra a
mini special move which allows us to do
this I am getting Street Fighter 2 vibes
here on top of that if we hold our 1
after completing a single combo we move
into this tempest form which focuses our
energy and our attack speed if we
complete two combos before halting our
one we unleash the Karma breaker a
lunging strike which deals damage over
time and if we hit all three of those
combos before pressing that r1 button we
unleash this beast the adamant bolts a
focused bolt of energy like something
from Dragon Ball Z Valletta beautiful of
course there's much more to this new
weapon than that but at a core basis the
ether strikers are so enjoyable to use
especially after a tough day at school
for work
the ether strikers are linked to the
lure of dauntless and in particular this
season's Hunt pass the sacred master and
her adamant fists have arrived at
Ramsgate as our new allies bringing with
them those eat the strikers and a
civilization unbeknownst to us the theme
of the season follows this law and if
you're new to the game the hunt pass is
like a battle pass you've seen other
free-to-play games or a season pass if
you prefer half the content is
completely free which includes this
dance do you recognize it it's from the
movie kickboxer absolutely great touch
dauntless depsite love it where was I oh
yeah hunt fast the second portion though
requires a little platinum to unlock and
has premium content for example one of
the early emotes in the past is this an
Hadouken yes even more Street Fighter
vibes coming from this it goes perfectly
well with that uppercut from the ether
strikers and a low key reminder that my
code and amaru works in the shop here
please think about repping my code for
more dauntless content on the channel
the hunt pass lets's cosplay as a monk
with colored eyes weapon skins and turns
more including variations to bounties
which are completely new let's break
those down bounties are a
brand-spanking-new system implemented
this season as a way to progress through
the hunt pass quicker previously we had
weekly missions to complete but after
feedback from the community the devs
have switched to bounties in the quest
and bounties tab we can select four
bounties to take out at the same time
but we do have autonomy here if you
don't like to use a hammer then don't
choose that bounty is simple as that to
want to concentrate on your ether
striker skills find a bounty which fits
your playstyle this makes the whole
experience much more customizable and if
I'm honest far more fun than those
weekly missions each day we are given
bounty tokens which are used to buy
bounties and switch between the ones you
don't like once you've run out simply
come back tomorrow and you'll be gifted
some more
[Music]
as we didn't eat up last month I'm going
to jump back a whole season and the
introduction of faction fight a brand
new way to compete choose aside equip
their sigil and earn points to determine
which factions Lantern will be awarded
to all yeah last season was very um
neon this is only early days of this
system but to gift an item after the
community choose aside and when the
battle is just an awesome touch and
follow that free item to really mean
something after the event it went back
up to full price in the store in
addition those on the winning side
received a discount in the store which
then feeds back into looking however you
want fashion is the endgame in dauntless
we'll have to wait and see what faction
fight evolves into but Phoenix labs have
shown continual improvement in
everything they do so I'm sure this
agenda another update has seen another
behemoth unleashed on the shattered
Isles this is the tempest bond storm
claw which plays much like a standard
storm claw fight but but holy it does
that I'm wrong it's a very different
fight and as always more behemoths
coming in future updates if we scratch
the surface of dauntless there are
improvements which may not be massive
but improve things more than we first
realize one of these improvements is in
the updated patrol system patrol
missions have daily rewards attached to
them but they do run out but as the name
suggests more are added each day
completing a hunt Awards these extras in
the lower right hand corner in the past
these prevented us from doing certain
missions as we had no choice but to use
our daily rewards on something we didn't
really want to but since then since the
update we can now opt in or opt out
preserving our daily patrol rewards so
go help a friend without feeling like
you're risking your daily rewards
another update we looked at last time
was the potential of loadouts while they
are now ready for action and in the game
we unlock six of these over the course
of the game's journey and more are
available through platinum if you need
more slots my personal favorite
improvement here is that the transmog
stay in place even when changing between
items and armor so if we need to switch
to the rift stalker armor but still want
to cosplay as a pirate a dauntless
as you covered and in another small
change loadouts can be copied into other
slots to make subtle changes I know that
doesn't sound like much but these things
add up to improve the quality of our
gaming lives and yet another tiny but
essential improvement to transmog into
another armor set only takes a single
transmog stone per item to unlock it
completely now the old system didn't
work as planned and Phoenix Lux have
rectified this GJ so now let's look into
the future of course there is far more
coming down the line dauntless one
update will see us face off against
multiple behemoths back-to-back a series
of behemoths in fact getting
progressively harder after each win we
are given a buff to help in the next
battle in the hopes of surviving 5
behemoths in her role that sounds like a
pretty good challenge and looking
forward to that one
Rams giving is on its way to which I'm
not too sure about but it looks like
dauntless his version of Thanksgiving if
you celebrate that in your country I
don't so I'm not completely cleared up
on what that is and then we have dark
harvest a Halloween themed event which
comes to dauntless every year when I saw
it back in 2017 it was like a nightmare
in a good way
everything was dark moonlit pumpkins
everywhere and we fought two behemoths
at the same time I think it was referred
to as the daily duo if I remember
rightly but that was two years ago so
we'll have to keep an eye on things and
see what they do this year but the way
they're linked it in with law back then
was so cool as this is the first version
of dark harvest in the full release
let's not potentially spoil things and
keep our hopes up for an awesome event
so there we have it 10 reasons to jump
back into dauntless let me know
thoughts about dauntless and if you'd
like more content from me I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade right now I'm going
back into the shattered Isles to punch
more behemoths in the face of happy days
I don't know why I like this so much
I'll see you soon right we are searching
for a firebrand cha rock dun dun dun dun
let's see if we know how to use 8 the
strikers yet I'm gonna punch the crap
are you dude oh dami that's good already
so if we keep moving he hasn't got a
chance he's far too slow
oh okay yeah okay okay okay you come for
a fight let's do this didn't like that
what's going on Colin I missed the last
hit through your face one mantra two
mantras three mantras let's do this oh
he took it he took it like a man
whatever that even means you took it
like a beam I can get into this way the
way of trying to get three mantras
without being hit that's pretty cool Oh
timing thanks mate let's go bro
[Music]
me float like a butterfly
we'll miss like an atom always down
let's knock him out some more in your
face there we go all three let's do this
your but there's all three again lights
out
eyes Cody don't run Colleen I miss you
already
you must be almost gone by now he
doesn't know what to do with himself
I'll give you a massage oh he's over
unlucky : that was a good fight good
fight good night do can I do like these
weapons
[Music]